Apuesto a que están preocupados.
(Risas)
Yo estaba preocupada. Por eso comencé esta obra.
Estaba preocupada por las vaginas. Estaba preocupada por lo que pensamos acerca de las vaginas,
y más preocupada porque no pensamos en ellas.
Estaba preocupada por mi propia vagina.
Necesitaba un contexto, una cultura, una comunidad de otras vaginas.
Hay tanta oscuridad y secretismo a su alrededor.
Como el Triángulo de las Bermudas, nadie envía jamás informes desde ahí.
(Risas)
En primer lugar, la vagina no es tan fácil de encontrar.
Las mujeres pasan, días, semanas, meses sin verla.
Entrevisté a una poderosa mujer de negocios,
me dijo que no tenía tiempo.
"Ver tu vagina," dijo, "es todo un día de trabajo."
(Risas)
"Tienes que recostarte de espaldas, frente a un espejo,
de preferencia largo. Te tienes que poner en la posición perfecta,
con la luz perfecta, y después se ensombrece por el ángulo en el que estás.
Estás girando la cabeza hacia arriba, arqueando la espalda, es agotador --"
ella estaba ocupada, no tenía tiempo.
Así que decidí hablar con las mujeres sobre sus vaginas.
Comenzaron como entrevistas informales sobre vaginas,
y se convirtieron en los "Monólogos de la vagina."
Hablé con más de 200 mujeres. Hablé con mujeres mayores,
mujeres jóvenes, mujeres casadas, lesbianas, mujeres solteras.
Hablé con profesionales corporativas, profesoras unversitarias, actrices, prostitutas,
hablé con mujeres afro-americanas, asiático-americanas,
nativo-americanas, caucásicas, judías.
Ok, al principio las mujeres eran un poco tímidas, un poco renuentes a hablar.
Una vez que comenzaban no había manera de pararlas.
A las mujeres les encanta hablar de su vagina, de verdad.
Sobre todo porque nadie se lo ha pedido antes.
(Risas)
Empecemos con la palabra vagina -- vagina, vagina.
En el mejor de los casos suena como una infección, o quizá como instrumental médico.
"Enfermera, de prisa, traiga la vagina"
(Risas)
Vagina, vagina, vagina, no importa cuántas veces
dices la palabra, nunca suena como una palabra que quieras decir.
Es una palabra totalmente ridícula, nada sexy.
Si tratas de utilizarla durante el sexo, tratando de ser políticamente correcta,
"Cariño, ¿me acariciarías la vagina?," matas el acto ahí mismo.
(Risas)
Me preocupa lo que las llamamos y lo que no las llamamos.
En Great Neck, Nueva York, le llaman "pussy-cat (gatita)."
Una mujer me dijo que su mamá solía decirle:
"No te pongas ropa interior bajo la pijama,
necesitas airear tu pussy-cat (gatita)."
(Risas)
En Westchester le llaman "pooky," en Nueva Jersey "twat."
Hay "polvera," "derriere," "pooky," "poochy," "poopy,"
"poopaloo," "pooninana," "padepachetchki," "pow" y "melocotón."
(Risas)
Hay "sapito," "dee dee," "nishi, "dignidad," "coochie snorcher," "cooter,"
"labi," "gladis siegelman," "va," "wee-wee," "parte puta," "nappy dugout,"
"mungo," "ghoulie," "polvera," "mimi" en Miami,
"split knish" -- Filadelfia -- y "schmende," en el Bronx.
(Risas)
Me preocupan las vaginas.
Asi es como comenzaron los "Monólogos de la vagina."
Pero en realidad no comenzó ahí, comenzó con una conversación con una mujer.
Estábamos hablando sobre la menopausia,
y llegamos al tema de su vagina --
que es lo que se hace cuando se habla de la menopausia.
Y dijo cosas sobre su vagina que me sorprendieron,
que estaba seca y acabada y muerta, y me sorprendió.
Entonces le dije a una amiga de pasada, "¿Qué piensas de tu vagina?"
Y esa mujer dijo algo más sorprendente,
y la siguiente mujer dijo algo más sorprendente,
y antes de saberlo, todas las mujeres me decían que tenía
que hablar con alguien sobre su vagina porque tenía una historia asombrosa,
y fui llevada por el camino de la vagina.
(Risas)
Y en realidad nunca me he desviado, creo que si me hubieran dicho
cuando era joven que al crecer estaría en tiendas de zapatos
y la gente gritaría "Ahí esta, la señora de la vagina,"
no creo que hubiera aspirado a eso en la vida.
(Risas)
Pero quiero hablar un poco sobre la felicidad y su relación
con este viaje de la vagina porque
ha sido un viaje extraordinario que comenzó hace ocho años.
Creo que antes de hacer los "Monólogos de la vagina"
en realidad no creía en la felicidad.
Para ser honesta, creía que sólo los idiotas eran felices.
Recuerdo cuando comenzé a practicar Budismo hace 14 años,
y me dijeron que el fin de la práctica era el ser feliz.
Dije, "¿Cómo puedes ser feliz y vivir en este mundo de sufrimiento,
y vivir en este mundo de dolor?" Confundía la felicidad con muchas otras cosas,
como adormecimiento, decadencia o egoísmo.
Y creo que lo que pasó en el transcurso de los "Monólogos de la vagina"
y en este viaje es que he llegado a entender
un poco más sobre la felicidad.
Hay tres cualidades de las que quiero hablar.
Una es ver lo que está frente a ti, hablar sobre eso,
y exponerlo. Creo que lo que he aprendido de hablar sobre la vagina,
y hablar sobre lo que es la vagina fue lo mas obvio --
estaba en el centro de mi cuerpo y en el centro del mundo--
y sin embargo era eso de lo que nadie hablaba.
La segunda cosa que hizo el hablar de la vagina
fue abrir esta puerta que me permitió ver
que había una forma de servir al mundo y mejorarlo.
Y de ahí es de donde ha venido la mas profunda felicidad.
Y el tercer principio de la felicidad, del que me he dado cuenta recientemente.
Hace ocho años, este momentum y esta energía, esta "Ola-V" comenzó --
y sólo la puedo describir como la "Ola-V" porque, para ser honesta,
no la entiendo por completo, me siento a su merced.
Pero la ola comenzó y si yo questionaba la ola,
o intentaba parar la ola o mirar atrás hacia la ola,
a menudo siento como un latigazo
o la probabilidad de romperme el cuello. Pero si sigo la ola,
y confío en la ola y me muevo con la ola, llego al siguiente lugar.
Y sucede de manera lógica, y orgánica y verdadera.
Y comencé esta obra, particularmente con historias y narraciones,
y hablaba con una mujer y eso me llevaba a otra mujer
y eso me llevaba a otra mujer, y entonces escribí esas historias
y las puse frente a otras personas.
Y cada vez que hacía el show en el inicio,
las mujeres literalmente hacían fila despues del show
porque querían contarme sus historias.
Y al principio pensé: "¡Fantástico! Me hablarán de orgasmos maravillosos
y vidas sexuales estupendas, y de cómo las mujeres adoran sus vaginas."
Pero de hecho, las mujeres no formaban para decirme eso.
Las mujeres formaban para decirme cómo habían sido violadas,
cómo eran maltratadas, y cómo eran golpeadas,
y cómo habían sido violadas en grupo en estacionamientos,
y cómo sus tíos habían cometido incesto.
Y quería dejar de hacer los "Monólogos de la vagina"
porque me parecía intimidante. Me sentía como una fotógrafa de guerra
que fotografía sucesos terribles, pero no interviene.
Así que en 1997, dije, "Juntemos a mujeres.
¿Qué podemos hacer con lo que sabemos sobre estas violaciones?"
Y resultó que, después de pensar e investigar,
descubrí - y las Naciones Unidas lo dijo recientemente --
que una de cada tres mujeres en este planeta
sera golpeada o violada en su vida.
Eso es básicamente el género que es el principal recurso del planeta, las mujeres.
Así que en 1997 juntamos a todas estas increíbles mujeres y dijimos,
"¿Cómo usar la energía de la obra para parar la violencia contra las mujeres?"
Y creamos un espectáculo en Nueva York, en el teatro,
y vinieron todas estas actrices famosas - desde Susan Sarandon,
y Glenn Close, hasta Whoopi Goldberg -- e hicimos una representación
una noche y ese fue el catalizador de esta ola, esta energía.
Y en cinco años, esto tan extraordinario comenzó a suceder.
Una mujer tomó esa energía y dijo, "Quiero llevar esta ola,
esta energía, a campuses universitarios," y tomó la obra
y dijo, "Usemos la obra y representemos la obra
una vez al año para recaudar fondos en contra de la violencia a las mujeres
en comunidades locales en todo el mundo."
Y en un año se presentó en 50 universidades y depues se expandió.
Y en los ultimos seis años se ha extendido
y extendido, y extendido, y extendido alrededor del mundo.
He aprendido dos cosas. Una que la epidemia
de violencia contra las mujeres es sorpendente, es global,
es tan profunda y tan devastadora,
y está tan enraizada en cada hueco de cada cráter
de cada pequeña sociedad que ni siquiera la reconocemos
porque se ha vuelto ordinaria. Este viaje me ha llevado a Afganistán,
donde he tenido el extraordinario honor y privilegio de ir a
partes bajo control talibán -- llevaba puesto un burka --
y fui con un grupo extraordinario llamado
Asociación Revolucionaria de Mujeres de Afganistán,
y vi de primera mano cómo las mujeres habian sido despojadas
de todo derecho del que se puede despojar a la mujer.
Desde recibir una educación, a tener un trabajo,
a poder comer helado.
Para aquellos que no lo saben, comer helado era ilegal bajo los talibanes.
Y de hecho vi y conocí a mujeres a quienes han azotado
al ser pilladas comiendo helado de vainilla.
Y me llevaron a una heladeria secreta en un pequeño pueblo,
fuimos a un cuarto trasero donde habia mujeres sentadas,
y se puso una cortina a nuestro alrededor, y les sirvieron helado de vainilla.
Y las mujeres levantaron sus burkas y comieron helado,
y creo que nunca entendí el placer hasta ese momento,
y cómo las mujeres han encontrado la forma de mantener ese placer.
Me ha llevado, este viaje, a Islamabad, donde he
conocido a mujeres con los rostros derretidos.
Me ha llevado a Juárez, México, donde estuve hace una semana,
donde he estado literalmente en estacionamientos
donde huesos de mujeres han aparecido tirados
junto a botellas de Coca-Cola.
Me ha llevado a universidades
de todo el país en donde se viola y droga a chicas cuando tienen citas.
He visto una violencia terrible, terrible, terrible.
Pero también he reconocido, al ver esa violencia,
que estar frente a estas cosas y ver lo que tenemos enfrente
es el antídoto contra la depresión y contra el sentimiento
de que uno es inútil y no vale nada.
Porque antes de los "Monólogos de la vagina,"
yo diría que el 80 por ciento de mi conciencia estaba cerrada a
lo que de verdad estaba pasando en esta realidad.
Y ese estar cerrada cerró mi vitalidad y mi energía.
Lo que también ha sucedido durante estos viajes --
y ha sido algo extraordinario – es que en cada lugar
al que he ido en el mundo, he conocido a una especie nueva.
Me encanta saber de todas esas especies del fondo del mar.
Y estaba pensando en cómo el estar con estas
personas extraordinarias en este panel concreto,
que está debajo, más alla y en medio,
y la vagina como que encaja en todas esas categorías.
(Risas)
Pero una de las cosas que he visto en esta especie --
y es una especie, y es un paradigma nuevo,
y nunca aparece en la prensa o en los medios
porque no creo que las buenas noticias sean noticia,
y no creo que la gente que está transformando el planeta
consiga grandes audiencias en televisión.
Pero en cada país al que he ido – y en los últimos seis años he estado
en cerca de 45 países y muchas aldeas diminutas, ciudades y pueblos --
he visto algo que he llegado a llamar “guerreros de la vagina.”
Un guerrero de la vagina es una mujer, o un hombre pro vagina,
que ha sido testigo de una violencia increíble, o la ha sufrido,
y en vez de tomar una AK-47 o un arma de destrucción masiva
o un machete, guardan la violencia en sus cuerpos,
viven el duelo, la experimentan, y después salen y dedican
sus vidas a asegurarse de que no le suceda a nadie más.
He visto a estas mujeres en todo el planeta.
Y quiero contar unas cuantas historias porque creo que
con historias transmitimos información,
que entra en nuestros cuerpos. Y creo que una de las cosas
de estar en TED que ha sido muy interesante
es que vivo mucho en mi cuerpo, y ya no vivo tanto en mi cabeza.
Y este es un lugar de mucha cabeza.
Y ha sido muy interesante estar en mi cabeza.
Estos últimos dos días he estado muy desorientada --
(Risas)
porque creo que el mundo, el mundo-V existe mucho en el cuerpo.
Es un mundo corporal, y la especie existe en el cuerpo,
y creo que hay un verdadero significado en
atar nuestros cuerpos a nuestras cabezas – que esa separación
ha creado una división que a menudo separa el propósito de la intención.
Y la conexión entre cuerpo y mente a menudo une esas cosas.
Quiero hablar de tres personas que he conocido,
guerreros de la vagina que han transformado mi entendimiento
de todo este principio y de la especie,
y una es una mujer llamada Marsha López.
Marsha López es una mujer que conocí en Guatemala.
Tenía 14 anos, y estaba en un matrimonio donde
su esposo la golpeaba con regularidad,
y no podía dejarlo porque era adicta a la relación
y no tenía dinero. Su hermana era mas joven que ella y mandó su solicitud
-- para el concurso “Frena la violación” que tuvimos en Nueva York hace años --
y mandó su solicitud, esperando ser finalista
y poder traer a su hermana.
Se convirtió en finalista y trajo a Marsha a Nueva York.
Organizamos un Día-V estupendo en un Madison Square Garden
lleno de testosterona, donde se agotaron todas las entradas,
18,000 personas de pie para decir
“sí” a las vaginas, lo que de hecho fue una transformación increíble.
Y vino, y fue testigo de esto, y decidió
que regresaría y dejaría a su esposo,
y que llevaría el dia-V a Guatemala.
Tenía 21 anos. Fui a Guatemala y ella había vendido todos los boletos
del Teatro Nacional de Guatemala.
Y la vi subir al escenario con su vestido rojo corto y tacones altos,
y se paro ahí y dijo. “Me llamo Marsha.